this is actually where it's more
interesting where you can't actually go
there so as an example I want you go to
consider this one but limit as X
approaches this okay so think about this
with me
what is this what is this thing if I ask
you to graph this you have another line
and you can graph it I don't think this
should stand out to you is the
denominator
what does innominate tell you about this
graph now I heard at least two different
things there which one we just hop right
the water which was more accurate what
this implies is a domain restriction
right X can't be equal to 2 because you
you can't divide by 0 you can't divide
anything by 0 ok because our numbers
blow up ok by the way one of the reasons
why you can't divide by 0 is because of
this and you get closer and closer to
dividing by 0 you don't get any sensible
values like from wonder if you go this
way the other here is that way so
there's not one value will agree or
unlike this ok but coming back to is
that kind of donut ok I should say x
equals 2 now the other thing I heard was
the vertical asymptote but there is not
a vertical asymptote if you go ahead and
draw this thing let me show you why
let's write and work with this things ok
um this is a bit of pain but I'm
promising you now this is a problem of
all your LM students during with maybe
this topic you are considering this
function at a particular value I've been
approaching this p value and this has
been continually stated every time you
work on this being so you have to
restate this for every line where you do
start working and people often forget to
do that I hope you can continue some
with the bag let's limit as X approaches
something of the function it's not just
the same as
the function okay those are two
different things one is a function once
is the number okay so you have to say
this over and over again which is a bit
of paper
trust me so I'm going to look at the
numerator and notice that I can do
something with the numerator that helps
me simplify things what can I do includi
factors right your factorization of
course is going to be x minus 2x plus 2
there's my numerator and then I have a
non oh okay
now at this point I'm going to point out
to make you notice now if that X 1 is 2
in there then that means we have this
domain restriction so X can never equal
to it's outside the domain okay which
means that here because I have this on
the numerator and the denominator X
minus T remember it's variable right to
pay or where X is X minus 2 can change
its value but you can tell me based on
this what X minus 2 we'll never be able
to wobble that never be equal to it will
never be equal to zero so therefore I
can multiply the top and bottom or
rather I can divide the top and bottom
by this because I do whatever it's going
to be it'll never be zero no I can state
it right here it flows directly regimes
there to subtract the two for most
scientists agree so seeing as X will
never be 2x minus 2 will never be 0 I'm
going to divide the top and bottom by
that love the euro so I don't care what
it is it's fine so that will I get this
right the limit again don't forget to
write a little bit you just get that
with this now what did for use is this
is just like the 30 table where you can
literally just put in the number you can
evaluate when x equals to key there's no
problem with that right as long as you
remember it can't actually beat you and
just think about how close I can get the
to what's a
so what does this look like jolly
sigelei this is what the graph looks
like remember as we went through our
simplification at one point this was
rewritten and this yes what is this talk
about why protects us to deliver just a
straight line is it so you can go
through - and maybe or - okay I'm going
to draw one of the thing that's - I've
been drawn this part of the line that's
what exhaustion looks like except when x
equals 2 when x equals 2
I'm not meant to exist right so how do
we indicate when something doesn't exist
when you exclude a single point what do
you do it's a hollow circle right like
that sort of sort of what motels rules
has many more broader applications than
just this and actually there are some
conditions in lockup of using
l'hopital's rule that we haven't
explained to you so be careful with that
what fatales rule is one of the easiest
things to misuse in all the calculus
because it's a cool tool that had
conditions that people often don't
patented you should be careful
um xcopy - but then after that he just
keeps on going on it's very wet right
like that so it's a straight line with a
hole punch dinner ok because x equals 2
that cyber domain but for all other
intents and purposes and go ahead solve
it some values you will find the x
squared minus 4 on X minus 2 looks
exactly behaves exactly like X plus 2
except for right there okay so nobody
Glasson sir do you notice that you're a
better class employee because
everything's just kind of simplified out
nicely
it's just that there's a hole so there's
a domain restriction without advance a
political operative okay
yes x squared minus four next one is to
intercept it - a little - to deter I
mean over here over an exit
effectiveness everyone is good with the
x intercept being - - well I figure out
how do we find the x intercepts given
that y equals zero right so you're going
to say okay this is I'm considering this
right now
like that okay so I'm going to let y
equal zero like you suggested like this
now related I suppose like a multiply
through by X plus two because it doesn't
matter what the denominator is
so you end up with this you already told
me how to factorize that right so I'm
getting this so tell me what the
solutions of disarm it's x equals
negative 2 and x equals 2 however you've
already told me that X can't be - so
therefore the only valid solution you
get out of this is negative 2 only right
just like this guy quick
these guys are mirror image of each
other like a mirror images a parallel
universe versions of each other except
that that part there that's be proven
difference between them okay